all right well uh congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
has coveted and just days after her
florida trip during which republicans
complained about
her not wearing a mask outdoors and
about her
partner's feet being exposed in
flip-flops and about her supposedly
fleeing liberal new york to conservative
paradise florida so there's a bunch of
different stories here that i want to
talk about and mostly it's about the
reaction from these people so axios
report aoc test positive for covid uh
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
has tested positive her office confirmed
sunday evening
they're saying she's experiencing
symptoms and recovering at home the
congresswoman received her booster shot
this fall encourages everyone to get
their booster and follow all cdc
guidelines also a report from pix11 in
new york aoc positive for covid
it wasn't immediately clear what her
symptoms were or how severe
and that's really the only additional
information we have now marjorie taylor
green very quickly took to twitter oh no
not twitter where was this this must
have been on uh
this must be on some right wing thing
maybe this is parlor i don't know where
she said so because margery taylor
green's banned from twitter margaery
says super jabbed and vaxxed aoc has
coveted what was that from all the
unvaccinated republican men she said
wanted to date her really it's because
coveted vaccines don't actually stop
anyone from getting sick with covid now
that's untrue as many of you know three
doses is 75 effective at preventing
symptomatic infection with omicron and
the overwhelming uh um
decrease in hospitalization and death
from the vaccine continues to be obvious
if you look at the numbers marjorie
taylor green whoop
also saying aoc caught the pandemic of
the unvaccinated even though she is
totally triple vaxxed she shouldn't take
that horse medicine ivermectin and
monoclonal antibodies are for people who
meet certain criteria like obesity and
over 55 and that's not her so a lot of
very strange gloating from marjory
taylor green but there's a couple of
different things here to talk about
here's a clip from this morning on cnbc
of andrew rossorkin and becky quick
talking about it in the meantime new
york representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez has tested positive for
covid19 her office released a statement
yesterday saying that she is
experiencing symptoms and recovering at
home
the statement also said that the
congresswoman received a booster shot
last fall but andrew over the holidays
there were lots of pictures of her
unmasked out and about in florida and
she was already picking up heat for the
fact that it was kind of she was saying
people shouldn't be doing these things
but she was pictured doing a lot of
these things in florida
so i think this will be additional
fodder for anybody who's looking to take
shots at her
you know
it's funny it's funny whether whether
getting covered now and i wonder whether
it's changed whether getting covert is a
scarlet letter i would think not i would
think there was there was a point early
on in this panel where people thought
okay so so
there's there's a bunch of different
things here
first of all
um
these people now gloating
are the ones who haven't been following
the guidelines all along
whose rates of covid are far higher in
red states than blue states in trump
counties versus biden counties whose
death rates are higher whose
hospitalization rates are higher so
why would they be mad at aoc now well
because of hypocrisy that would be the
explanation hypocrisy okay
did aoc violate any rules and the answer
is as far as i know she didn't uh she
wore a mask when traveling down to
florida
and she was outdoors and not wearing a
mask and okay so you could say well but
she's advocating for things to be rules
which then she ignores no she didn't
ignore any rules she wore the mask on
the plane okay whatever so what's the
lesson here
the lesson is this is so insanely
contagious
and these right-wingers have continued
to say
all of this stuff is bs
leave liberal new york and come to safe
florida where desantis is doing
everything great and it's so safe and
we're doing great on covid well
hospitalizations in florida are up 200
plus percent since the start of this
omicron wave but aoc went to florida and
she got coveted so clearly it must not
be that safe now we're assuming that the
covid is a result of her having been in
florida if you think about the timing
she was in florida over the new year
into the into the new year and then she
came back and most people have two to
three days asymptomatic then symptoms
start sometimes it takes another day two
or three before you even show up as
positive and then you know we got to
sunday night which was was the ninth
we're presuming that this was the result
of being in florida it it may not even
be we we really don't know but it
doesn't matter um the the the idea here
is
all of these
right wing it's it's
likely that it happened as a result of
that trip
uh and all of these right-wingers who
say you got to come down to florida it's
actually safer here it doesn't actually
appear to be also remember
that we know she has coveted because she
got tested
and recently the florida surgeon general
has been saying we got to do away with
this testing culture
you know testing testing all the time
she could have followed that
and never gotten a positive test and
just lived her life and exposed more
people and on and on and on but she's
not doing that she's actually going to
go to a quarantine so
without a doubt what aoc did is risky
right now like this is so contagious you
know when i flew back a few weeks ago
every the entire airport was just filled
with coughing people i don't know how i
didn't get it uh but the people calling
her out are doing the exact same stuff
so the moral of the story
it really is that contagious
um and i'm gonna be doing very little
for a couple of weeks and i want the
peak to be over and hopefully we'll have
far better looking numbers uh in in a
few weeks um the the other thing just to
consider is
it could have been going to florida
when she's in the bronx or wherever you
know new york city has an insanely high
positivity rate right now she's meeting
constituents she's going to ribbon
cutting she's doing all that stuff
she's in harm's way because of her job
with without question and ultimately i
don't know that it even really matters
where she got it but that's the latest
republicans gloating about aoc catching
covid
there are so many interesting and new
types of assets anyone could invest in
today wine sneakers artwork and many
others but the big question is
which ones actually make sense and
that's why i'm such a big fan of our
sponsor alts alts is a newsletter
that will demystify these investment
markets and assets for you whether we're
talking video games or baseball cards
music rights comic books alts does the
analysis for you and it's an analysis
that nobody else is doing they do
extremely deep research to give you
valuable insights but alts is not just
about information it's also about
recommendations and you can check out
their excellent performance track record
on their website there are a ton of new
ways to diversify your portfolio
intelligently right now
but you have to know how to navigate
them and understand them and alt makes
it easy to understand go sign up for
free
at davidpakman.com
alts the link is down below